With the feedback about the engineers, so yesterday we had a connect, we spoke about Karthikey in length, and per the discussion that we had, that we were, I was able to connect with him, coach him on the expectations, and I think most of the things were lined up on that very call itself, but still.
I made sure that I revisit him and check that we if he got it or not. So he did and he made sure that he would work on the learnings from this mistake. So this is something that he's aligned.
It's.
Great.
Right.
Next is about the rest of the engineers. So I just wanted to know how did they perform in the past two weeks and how would you see them working on different tickets?
Um...
I think, well, Nitin is out, but Nitin tends to be very diligent from what we see on his tickets. One thing that I'm trying to push the team on in general, by the way, is to close their tickets.
I.
off. My thinking is that, especially for tier ones, they should not come Friday afternoon. They should have next to zero.
tickets on them because they should have either remedied or escalated those. I think that's a fair expectation. You know, borrowing a customer who might have ghosted them, they might have an actual schedule call with them for the next week.
Yep.
But I think, especially for tier one, that's my that's my goal, and Jacob Richardson is trying to has been trying to push that, but I would appreciate your pushing that same mode of stuff around that, because I think you know Friday afternoon is a little bit more quiet from our queue, and it's a good time for them to have caught up.
on those one or two that might have still been in their plate. With that in mind, you know, it's good for us to start off Monday afresh and, you know, back a last week again. Right. So that's exactly the tempo that I want to set. So with that,
I.
In mind, I kind of highlight to, you know, Nitin going off, you know, how many tickets he might have still had on him, assigned to him accordingly, and okay, well, you know, we need to work on that because some of those the indefinitely and there's no follow up, there's no escalation as well, so it was good that the the other team members were.
Mhm.
holding on, covering for him and Karthik while he was on leave as well for those couple of days. I think thanks so much for that, making that shift accordingly. One thing that Jacob Richardson pointed out in the chat was we see Ronan popping in and out.
to suit. And, you know, yeah, we take breaks as necessary for sure, right? You know, grab a tea, coffee, etc. But the timing of it sometimes is also very...
Key yesterday, I think it was he mentioned Ronan might have been absent, but also in the morning period when he was covering before our 8:00 CST, I did see a couple missed calls from our customer. They called in a couple minutes after and he was able to.
Thank you.
to handle that call, but that told me that, hey, he was not there at the desk taking calls at that point in time. I can.
I can grab that screenshot. Sorry, I can grab that screenshot and send it to you as well. It was not, it wasn't something that I brought up at a point in time because I saw that the customer called right after. So, you know, it wasn't anything that need to be actioned or something to be discussed with you to suit because I don't want that trend.
Yu.
Thakur. Of course, as you all can imagine, 8 o'clock in the morning is our peak time when customers call in, they're now signing in or trying to sign in and they can't sign in or something isn't working, et cetera, something broke overnight or whatever, right? Or they just have a note and they are now about to follow up with us.
The.
Yep.
So I think, I think, yeah, I think we need to be, I want to be very tied to this, else we're going to backslide to the situation that we had when I first came. And that's something I need to make sure that we're on the board with. We've addressed it. I was, I myself was personally
seeing about it and making sure and seeing and finding out who was on cue and why they weren't signed in or put as active. And I think we have a couple of people slipping with that. That being said, there's also the situation on the schedule where sometimes
techs are not coming back into the queue on time after their breaks or their lunch. And as a result, we have other guys who are holding on, not taking their lunch on time because they really think we feel to come back in as well, right? So because they understand that there needs to be coverage. You can't just...
you know, often leave, etc. So I know there will be a bit of flexibility there sometimes when you're on a call and you might take your lunch late because you know you were just on a call, etc. But let's make sure that that's communicated within the team and that people are trying to stick to their schedule.
Yeah.
The.
as best as possible.
Ray.
Yep, yep, yep.
I think.
Uhh.
The other texts, Jacob Richardson, probably would have any more details that he would want to share, but he's not going to join today, as mentioned. But I think that overall feedback from him was positive for the last week or so. I don't agree. I think everything that we had, we escalated to suit.
Ohh, would care one text?
Yep.
That being said, we had a we had an interesting couple of weeks here where we had that those two incidents. And I also noted to yours moving forward. I do want to make sure and I
Yeah.
see where we need to make sure that we are being tied with our processes and procedures and policies and making sure that the team knows exactly what's allowed or what's not allowed to suit. Yeah.
I.
Yep, yep, we are completely aligned with this, Justin. Yep, yes, please complete your thought.
Um...
Yeah.
Sure, yeah, I know that we have something pending for you, which is technically keeping back productivity on the tier ones, which is the access to those virtual machines so that the techs can log in to Microsoft 365 tenants for customers. And yes, that's on us. We have a...
Internal resources who are trying to work on it to suit, and that's where the pushback is right now. It's not resources that I control, as that might have been done a little faster, but you know, please bear with us. I know Jeremy has set a timeline for it to get done in.
in June, I think he said, which is kind of far out. But I'll try to see if we can get it faster, but we have those constraints on our side.
Sure.
I.
I don't know if, well, Karine might not have been aware of the incident with Karthik, but I believe she would have been in the loop with Sterling. Just to bring you into the one, the issue with Karthik, there was a slight misconfiguration.
that was done by a customer on Friday last week, where it stopped services, email services for that customer for a couple hours. And the team thought it was a compromise, so we dealt with it like a security compromise, and we spent some time, even about 3 hours.
over time as well, too, for some of one of the techs as well to work on it and the security team got engaged. But all in all, we smoothed it over the customer and let them know what transpired. So we followed up. We had a follow up meeting with Ashish, Amit, Jacob Richardson, Karthik and myself.
And Karthik mentioned that it was a careless mistake as he was working on too many things at the same time. And that's what Ashish had mentioned earlier.
Yep.
A forgivable mistake. I just want to put it out there. We all make mistakes and this one was not malicious. It was not going outside process. It was just a slip of a mistake of copying the wrong address to suit.
The.
Yeah.
Hey, Karine, we opened up a replacement request also in front of Jessel to choose. But I think, like Jessel said, that it is a forgival mistake. So we, again, we are not taking it lightly, for sure. We currently have a plan open internally with him where we have been tracking his performance daily and weekly.
But at the same time, this is now on high alert because he cannot afford to make any certain mistakes. So yeah, just for your awareness.
Alright.
Yeah.
Thank you so much, Jessel, for sharing this feedback. And yeah, so when you mentioned regarding the call queue thing that I was looking at the note of, so I will certainly have a word with the team to make sure that they are logging back into the queue one time when they are coming back from the breaks.
Thanks.
Yeah.
So this is something that I'll have a word with them. Second is, I know, in the previous weeks, we have been sharing the screenshots of any calls which went to missed state or the calls that rang into Nimbus but could not come into the team's side.
So I've not seen any such snips coming in from a week or so. So just wanted to know, is it something that is running fine or is it something that you're not doing anymore? Fix it.
Honestly, this week has been so horrendous with the major outages that we had from Teams itself going down to ConnectWise, being out, the data center having a major failure in Saskatoon, as well as even power outages in the Winnipeg office.
it has been horrendous and I have been, you know, trying to put out those fires and I haven't been on it as I usually am. But that being said, you know, even though we had those major and I would, you know, have some leniency, especially when we have major updates.
Hello.
Exceptional, exceptional number of calls, so you know what? Let me, let me share, let me share my screen so I can show you exactly, exactly, paint that picture for everybody, including Karine, right?
To.
Kour.
This is the number of calls that we get typically, right? And on these are the Mondays, right? The 6th, the 18th, right? Where the total calls might have been 30 something, you know, below 30 for some days, 40 something. This Monday we had 88.
Yu.
which is literally more than double what we normally have. And of course, there would be some missed calls as a result, because many people are calling in the team and trying to find out what's going on on our side. Again, in spite of that, the team still did about 80%.
reachability, which is highly commendable, to be honest. And we did it necessary to battle that. So if I look at a seven day average, then we're still at 87%. So that was still pretty good handling by them.
As I said, I haven't been on it because of time metrics as well as, you know, especially with global outages, there are going to be some miscalls. So I have been a bit lenient into that and looking at that. Okay.
The.
Kip.
Like.
Yeah, I think we're we're we we will resume my my due diligence on it next week.
Yeah, it was helping a lot because anything that we noticed that this call was missed, that would give me the opportunity to reach out to the engineer and check the reason behind why it was missed. At times it was an honest mistake and at times it was something that was a technical glitch. So we just need to be sure.
Like, what was the reason behind the call was not getting answered, and the status went to Rana, so this is something that was giving visibility to me as well, so yeah.
Right.
Yes, I think I think only the only person who noted that they having like Atul Teams glitches is Ronan, right? I want to say maybe we look at reinstalling Teams altogether for him because I suspect that he's having some some sort of technical issue on his end because he says sometimes it rings and he can't.
Yep.
Pick up.
And anybody who's had that issue, they've reinstalled Teams and that seemed to resolve the issue. I mean, even customer-wise, right? That tends to happen, or they're not, is not only the latest update of Microsoft Teams, and then, you know, if we're not only latest Teams, then things can go haywire, right?
So, yeah, I I don't mind if if you take a look at that, but this is this is a view on it. There's some other stats that I'm working on as well, where...
where we would see, this is for the year thus far, and this is something I probably schedule a different meeting for us to go through and discuss and see exactly how people have been performing. And then I can also limit that by the last couple of weeks where we've made that change into direct.
call routing instead of broadcast. Because I think the broadcast is going to skew our thinking and how we want to monitor this going forward.
You.
Yeah.
Yep.
Yeah, there's some there's some quick numbers on something now we cannot, this is, yeah.
Yeah, if, if you could, you know, maybe share a report of last month or last 30 days with me for these engineers, that would be that would be helpful when I have these discussions with them, showing their data to them, so that they are, if they want to, you know...
Well, explain it to me, so they should they should have a proper justification against it, not just something random that it was a technical glitch or I was on break, something like that.
Yes, yes, but not only that, you know, even with the mindset of from a service management standpoint, do we see a common trend happening with a particular tech that we address it and and they are noting a technical issue, right? So we should we should investigate and or at least try a few things in order to remedy. So that's what I'm thinking, you know, if Rana is mentioning he's...
Mmh.
he's been having some challenges trying to answer the calls, then yeah, let's make sure that he, yeah, we do the necessary reinstall of Teams and or see if there's some performance issues on his machine.
So this is on us, so we'll take care of it.
Thanks so much. Yeah. Yeah, other than that, well, the one that I left for last is that issue with Sterling. And I think, you know, as we agreed, moving forward, we want to make sure that we're very tight on
Take him to bed.
understanding and policies and noting that we have to hold ourselves to a very high standard as it relates to information security and make sure that, you know, we know we have the keys to the data, the keys to the kingdom, as they say.
The.
as IT system administrator. But what we do is that is very important and make sure that we don't cross certain lines and delve into information that we shouldn't have. All right. And that, and not to scare Karine in any way, but you know, some of us have sat as system administrators and
Yep, yep.
and would have access to, you know, you name it, payroll information, HR information, which we ought not to look at. And we don't, even though we might have a way in which to get into it. That's also part of the job, right, to know how to...
to do those things if necessary, right? But yeah, we don't because of the controls that we should have in place as well as the responsibility put on the tech to suit, right?
So.
Yep, I am aligned with this.
Perfect.
Yeah, so I do, you know, keep sending some of those good resources to me. I have an interview data with one of your colleagues as well. And I look forward to that one in particular. So I asked for an hour and not just half an hour, because I think that might be a longer conversation.
Sure. Yeah, that has been moved. He is an offered candidate of ITBD, but of course he has not joined, right? So he will join on 27th, right? This is what I mentioned to you, Karine. Right. And yeah, and then you level, if you choose to go ahead with him, if he makes the cut, then of course.
OK.
Hoh.
first week of induction and then he should be able to get started with you.
Okay, okay, great. What I would want to do is try to tie in that level one and level 2 at the same time, so we do onboarding at the same time for those two as best as we can, because it takes a bit of time and effort to onboard separate resources, you know, and and we do have, yeah, we do have a...
Yeah.
Yep, yep.
Understood.
Another internal resource and starting the first week of May as well, too, so if we can, if we can aim for that, then that would be great.
Sure, sure.
I like, I like those efficiencies.
Yeah.
Yeah, that's something that makes sense.
Yep.
Okay, anything else that you wanted to Karine, anything you wanted to read in particular?
Thank you so much.
No, no, I'm just waiting for the your another Allan, and that's it, yeah.
That's the first purity, right? Amit, another L1. Okay. Are you, do you have somebody in process, a few candidate in process?
Yes, yep.
Yes, we selected one candidate, technical and operations both. Now the TA team is connected with him for the documentations, et cetera. If everything comes clean, then of course we will be sending the resume to you.
Thank you.
Okay.
Don't forget to put the start date also. That will help us to figure it out. Okay.
Yeah, that's the standard. That's the standard. Yep, yep.
Yep, thank you.
OK.
Tell me.
I just want to give you a quick update, Jessel, that post that security incident, we ensured that every engineer working with MSP Corp is trained on data security and best practices. So that training has been done for every engineer. So this is something that we took care of.
Awesome.
proactively and made sure that this is this happens and it happened.
Okay, great. I appreciate that. Thanks. Was this was this post the incident or prior to the incident that you had that session?
The.
You're welcome.
It was after the email that we received from Allan.
Okay.
Both incident.
Okay, yeah. Okay, great. Thanks so much.
So that's going to be our standard process, Jessel, that although these topics are covered, but just wanted to be double sure about anybody who starts with MSP Corp going forward, they will have to go through that module of training in addition to their training assessments to make sure that they have a fresh awareness of the.
MSP Corp expectations in terms of the security and other things before they're even starting with you guys.
Perfect, perfect. Thank you. Appreciate that.
Thank you.
There are, there are a couple of changes coming underway, um, uh, internally, uh, especially we've uh...
The team tends to join our bi-weekly technical services meeting. And within that, Jeremy tends to rule out different process changes and or policy changes. One of those that I said I would mention to you all is something we flagged, and I even discussed it with Alvin as well, where
We were recording user credentials at the request of customers in order to assist them with, you know, keeping track on that and somebody forgot their password. But we've since outlawed that altogether by one of the policies that we have. So it's a transition that we're making and
S.
Meaning that we want to make sure that we're not storing any customers' username and passwords for them in any way, being custodians of that. The only thing we would hold is the global admin, as you all know, domain admin accounts that we have created for ourselves. So we know it's a
MSP Corp employee that's logging in, you send those credentials, right? So that's a change that is going to happen pretty rapidly where we remove all of those username and passwords to safeguard ourselves and the technicians as well.
It.
There may be complaints that it makes their job a little bit more difficult, but this is what's necessary in the world that we live in today.
Yeah.
Right? So I'm surprised that that's a practice here because I've never seen that before. That's not something that you do. You might have had like the first time you've set up that customer, the temporary password that they got and upon first login, they change it themselves. That's the only thing that you might have had at any point in time.
Kip.
But that's rare as well too, right? That's very rare. So we want to do that. There are a couple of changes to the workflow within ConnectWise. That's going to be done as well too. I will set up a separate session to go through that with you, Ashish.
So that we understand, and this is in relation to how what emails are sent out to a customer based on status changes within ConnectWise, so we have we have minor tweaks being done to that in order to help the text as well as.
Kour.
to really streamline our processes better and have that communication with. So I will cover it with the team as well.
Tomorrow, with the with the tier ones and then and the tier 2 for that matter, but I will I will cover it with you as well, Ashish, so you're aware of that minor change.
People.
I appreciate it, Jessel.
Yeah.
K.
I just have a quick question on the similar lines. So what I know is, correct me if I'm wrong, that whenever engineer is working on any ticket and the note that he would put in, if those notes are technical enough, I believe they remain as non-customer-facing notes.
Sure.
Isha.
And only such information needs to go as customer facing note, whatever you want your customer to be known about. That's one. Second is when we are closing the ticket during the resolution time and we are entering the resolution notes, only those note needs to go out to the customer.
Yes.
But we have to ensure that we don't mention any technical details like the steps we took, the process we followed, and how we got to the resolution, right? We just have to mention that this was a problem and this is probably.
Yes, it's briefly.
It might be high level, right? It might be high level, right? Where they said, okay, I have, I have, if it's a password reset, then it's clear cut, right? I've reset your password with X, Y, and Z, right? That could be internal and external. There's some exceptions, so that way it's very simple, a simple action that they might have done.
I live, yes.
Yes, if it's something more technical and it's detailed steps, et cetera, that would be internal. And there's resolution notes, sorry, there's the notes that are the final fix should be marked as the resolution on it.
Right, yeah, that's the only thing I wanted to get clarity on.
Yeah.
Yeah, okay.
Okay.
Anything else, Jessel, you want to share?
And that's it.
No, no, other than it's been good working with you folks, to be honest, even though we have some rough times, I appreciate the openness, the honesty, and our discussions accordingly. I do appreciate that, I must say.
Kip.
And I also thankful to you, Jessel and Karine, for giving us the opportunity to collect the things which were missing in order to know, trusting in us, believing in us, and giving us the opportunity to serve you again. So yeah, I really appreciate that. And thank you. Yes, I missed it. Sorry, I
Thank you, Jessel.
Thank you.
No, no, that's fine. I think it's pretty much the same sentiments we have. We had a very brief discussion, Karine, you were not there on the call, so we were discussing with Reza, right, and we were going through the JD, and we were like, a lot of skills there, but in order for us to be 100% sure that...
what is good to have and what is nice to have. Can we go about segregating, right, so that we are, when we are presenting, we are presenting candidates which are non-negotiable, right, in terms of the skill set. So there could be 10 skill set written in the resume, but without those non-negotiable skill sets, we're not going to present anybody.
So we were able to do that exercise, right? And I think for your pod also, we have a fair understanding based on that discussion. But Ashish, you may want to send this to Karine and Karine can now to Jessel to validate for the L1 plus candidates that we are presenting. And Jessel, do let us know if there is anything changes because we want to change a little bit of more.
Yep.
Like.
Around that.
Okay, and Mayur, if you send it to me as well, so that he's aware of that too. I have been chatting with Reza here and there, and it's good that we're trying to set standards all around from MSP Corp. He has a good experience as well, too, so I...
Yeah.
Sure.
I don't mind taking a look at that and adopting it if we need to.
Okay, Amit, are you talking about L1 plus candidate?
Yes, L1 plus L2. So basically we, for every candidate, we already have the JD, we have been presenting, we have a fair understanding, but we're trying to find out the non-negotiable skills, right? Which about, without which, I mean, a candidate must not go through. So yeah.
Okay.
Okay, but I understand that. If you're presenting at one class other business unit, I also need to be approved because the price is not the same. You remember the exercise we did with Mayur teams? What do you say?
Yeah, yeah, so we're not changing that. Yes. We're not changing any of that. We are going by exactly the JD that you have given us. We are pulling out the information from the JD. We will not go outside the JD. Great, just to be clear. Yeah.
Oh, OK.
Okay.
Okay, perfect. Okay.
No.
Kip.
Good.
That's good.
OK, I have to hop to another meeting, but it was good chatting with Johal. OK, talk soon. Take care. Bye.
All right.
Yep.
Yep, same here, Jessel. I'll share the deck in the email. Yeah, thank you.
Thank you.
Okay.
Bye.
Thank you. Bye.
See.